[Music]
[Applause]
Chris Fowler ESPN college football and
Tennis host and a proud Colorado grad
good to have you back on the program
there Chris let me take you back to when
Dion got hired your reaction was what as
a Colorado grad
my reaction first of all was he wasn't
going to take the job he was just
teasing uh but they did a great job you
know selling him on the fact that
Colorado would give him what no one
other school would give him which was
carte blanche to do it his way without
um a lot of
no no no no no no you can't do this
can't do that I think that was
attractive to him I think he actually
loved the scenery out there that's not
acting I I didn't know for sure they
would have this kind of quick success
stand but I knew the roster needed an
overhaul when you were on the slab cold
dead concrete as a program boom you need
somebody to go in there and shock it to
life because
energy is better than no energy you know
Buzz is better than no buzz belief is
better than no belief I didn't think
that he'd be able to sell that Vision to
as many top recruits as he has and and
overhaul the roster in a way we've never
seen it done before man that was fun to
watch that TCU game I I admit I was
stunned man I did not think they could
go out there and execute like that and
beat a team that beat Michigan in the
playoffs last year uh I was I was
euphoric I was proud but I was really
surprised
how sustainable do you think it is in
his first year that yes he did surprise
TCU but now you kind of come back to
you're not surprising anybody
no Nebraska and Colorado State are two
Rivals uh coming in the next couple of
weeks and I thought from the start that
the success of this season might be
defined by those two games I expected a
loss in Fort Worth I'm not going to lie
I didn't believe uh as coach Prime would
say but uh I I do believe they could
beat Nebraska and CSU I think they're a
slight favorite in that game so there
are still a lot of Skeptics Matt rule I
expected them to get a bump that was a
disappointing loss they had to Minnesota
in in game one uh they'll bring it I
mean Dion he laughed at me when I said
you've made your team a big Target every
game just by your presence and your
personality he laughed and said I'm used
to a big Target said yeah you are
because the whole world this roster has
never been a Target Dan they've never
been the focus of any opponent so we'll
find out how they handle their own
success I think they should win the game
they're hard to stop you're gonna have
to score points to beat them
but that spring game when I tuned in for
that spring game and I go tune in for
the spring game I did accidentally I was
doing a drive-by and all of a sudden I
go oh wait Colorado's Gotta Wait what
are they showing like a rear of a
Colorado game and then a spring game
like wow that that to me was like okay
they may not be good but they're
relevant because they know it's flying
Dion was concerned about the field
wanted to cancel the game there's all
kind of phone calls going on in the
morning he said no we can't stick around
and do it tomorrow you need to play it
today his kidur was out there in the
snow I don't think he'd ever seen or
played in snow and was spinning the ball
and they executed and the crowd showed
up that it was I said this is Colorado
we're going to show up in the snow don't
worry about that it was filled I called
it from the field uh which is a one-off
experience and it almost got run over
twice where they blocked kicks and ran
them back near us RG3 is sprinting down
the sideline I mean it was one of those
things where like you kind of have a
roster but you really don't know what's
going on out there and then it turns out
after the spring game you know about 60
guys were out and about 60 new guys were
in but it was it was a you got a sense
there Dan of the unique like singular
energy that he can bring and the and the
people were just along for the ride if I
said you could only watch one Texas
Alabama or Colorado and Nebraska
well I'm not watching Texas bam I'm
working so I am I am expected to watch
it well no no that's a college football
fan not not broadcast they're on
different times no you only get one come
on
well would you want you want a fun
experience you want to go with the the
the uh Bolder Vibe or you want something
that's like Armageddon that has playoff
implications I mean I would pick your
poison
uh
I I might I might pick Colorado against
Nebraska because I I'm just curious you
know they come down a little bit here
can Matt rule get Nebraska going after
losing against Minnesota
um Texas Alabama obviously is spicy I
guess let's enjoy Dion while we can and
then we'll get to you know the rest of
college football the big games later in
the season is that fair I hope the Bucks
keep rolling I mean I think it is a
great story it was just pure fun okay
people went to the spring game you
talked about who had never been to
Colorado never seen a buffalo's game
they were just drawn by the
gravitational pull of Coach Prime and
they showed up in Boulder and I think
there are people I know there are people
around the country watching that team
that have nothing to do with the program
it's just fun and there's like an
exuberance and a freshness and a
difference to it now there's also a lot
of people want to see them lose because
you don't come in and revolutionize the
sport that's built on tradition and
moves at a glacial Pace usually really
in the way he has and not piss some
people off and turn some people off but
that that's also what makes it fun is
that whatever you think of them you're
thinking of them talking to Chris Fowler
ESPN college football announcer and of
course uh he's been working at the U.S
open we'll get to that coming up here in
a moment the uh Alabama Texas matchup
comes down to what
I mean it's going to come down to
situational football but Texas is Big
physically they're they're they look the
part they're not going to lose in the
warm-up the way a lot of opponents do
against Alabama
um I think it's going to be defense I
think it's going to be last last year's
game was low scoring right selling had
to make an escape kick a late field goal
to escape the the game in Austin
um I think I think it's defensive game
this time too
um I think Texas feels equipped to deal
Alabama's got three guys in the
offensive line band who are 350 plus
okay and that just huge it's not soft
weight we've never seen an offensive
line that can Mash people like that so
it's going to be just big bodies on big
bodies and then you know who can make a
play in the Red Zone it's more like a
Sunday game that way it's not going to
be frantic Pace I don't think I think
they'll play at a regular pace and it'll
be physical and and you know who can who
could make a play in the red zone and
you know Alabama's jail and milro has
had one start he looked good but minimal
resistance in the opening game it's real
Tennessee a much tougher assignment for
him against Texas so I think points to
the premium
explain to me how we came up with the
idea of keeping the clock running
late in the game as as you know with
first downs Lane kiffin said it's like
going to see a country con you know
concert and they leave out two songs
that like basically you know Chip Kelly
is you know had some criticisms like hey
I hope you're getting your commercials
in there who came up with this idea
Chris
of the NFL they're basically just
copying the NFL clock rules because they
saw that college games Dan does anybody
really want to have a three hour and 50
minute game I I know kiffin wants as
many plays as possible
um it's going to cut down five or six
plays it's gonna it's gonna shorten the
game time we don't have enough data know
how long but I mean it's really you do
see a difference though you know how in
the NFL you're watching the game and a
team's trying to make up a deficit and
there's five six minutes on the clock
you better play that drive with urgency
and teams in college just haven't had
that so you're seeing some clock
management challenges early on but I
like it because I don't like a three
hour and 50 minute game man this could
be going
I didn't realize you know I went to Ohio
State Michigan a couple of years ago in
Columbus and the commercial breaks are
interminable when you're there but when
you're at home and you're flipping
around you're doing something it's not
as impeding as it is when you're sitting
there and you're going wow this is a
long long time in between you know punts
and getting the field back you know guys
back out on the field there am I
sounding like an old man a long time
when you're in the booth too
I think the brakes are about the same as
an NFL game halftimes are much longer in
college everything has sort of been you
know bigger longer sloppier than than
the pro game I don't have any problem
with getting games done quicker
uh you've been covering the U.S soap and
explain to America who Ben Shelton is
he's a uh a lightning bolt they just
landed an Arthur rash Stadium who has
struggle with consistency but has a big
enough game isn't served at 149. he
brings it like an exuberance and energy
um a naivete that's almost beneficial
when you get in these big stages because
you don't get nervous he's never been at
the semi-final stage of any tournament
on the tour even the little tiny ones
they call them 250s never made a
semi-final there finds himself in the
U.S open semi-final against the dude
that's been in 47 grand slam semifinals
that's just one of joke of it just many
absurd numbers but the dude has a
puncher's chance I was talking to Johnny
Mac puncher's chance because a lefty
serve at that speed even the greatest
returner ever hasn't really felt that
now he'll probably settle in and figure
it out but you know listen Shelton
doesn't have Scar Tissue like a lot of
dudes who play Djokovic do right they go
in with a lot of scar tissue from past
losses this guy doesn't even know what
he doesn't know yet so let's see it it's
been great he's beaten two higher ranks
more accomplished American guys to earn
this spot and let's see what he can do
today when did the dip or why did the
dip happen with American tennis
certainly on the men's side
a good question I mean people have
criticized Player Development um our
best athletes not going into the sport
there was a couple of generations there
where you know you have some some
players who are accomplishing things but
not at the majors
um the sheer money we have the resources
we have the fact that it's actually
easier to achieve a good ranking as an
American because of the volume of tennis
tournaments we have and the
opportunities to to build your ranking
without even going across the border
Michelle had never been out of the
country by the way until the Australian
Open didn't have a passport goes down to
the Australian Open and it makes the
quarters I mean it's it's incredible
where he came from but I think now we're
there I don't know if we have in this
current group someone who could be
Carlos alcaraz and win a major Dan
because I don't think not many people
are going to do that this dude is set up
to dominate
um maybe even as soon as Sunday but
certainly in the post Djokovic area
you're gonna have to catch up to him so
I don't know if these guys like Taylor
Fritz Tommy Paul Francis ciafo Shelton
are capable of of winning a major
anytime soon but it's fun to have them
in the mix we love to rank who's the
greatest I know it's generational with
going back to Rod Laver and all of those
different players Generations here but
Djokovic doesn't really matter what the
surface is uh I mean I don't know where
you stand with that with Federer
Djokovic or other with that label of uh
goat
well the doll's in the conversation and
he had the most until Novak just passed
him what's interesting is in tennis we
tend to only look at
the number of Majors you want on the
resume I mean how do you decide who's
the greatest quarterback of the NFL is
is it Brady is it is it somebody else I
mean you know is it the most Super Bowls
I mean in baseball how do you pick the
greatest baseball player I
I mean in tennis you can go buy a resume
if you're going to go by the facts Novak
has the greatest resume period if you're
going to go buy did they influence the
sport did they grow it globally did they
do something we had never seen before I
mean
Federer fans believe he he changed the
game globally in a way the other guys
did that all fans would look at you know
his ability to to adapt and grow his
game and Annex different territories I
mean but if you go by a resume it's
becoming clearer and it will become more
clear if uh if Djokovic wins on Sunday
here I remember uh peach sampers saying
to me I said what do you think of uh
Federer this is a long time ago he said
he attempts shots that I wouldn't
consider even trying like he you know
that just the imagination you have to I
think we sometimes underestimate or
don't factor in the imagination you must
have as a shot maker and and you know
Federer has that certainly
yeah that's what I mean you know Maya
Angelou has the quote and I've used it
before in this goat argument people
remember not what you did but how you
made them feel okay when people watch
Federer play tennis they had a feeling
that they never got from anybody else
right and and it's just it's that
creativity that beauty that Elegance
that smoothness uh that that
Djokovic and Nadal don't have so Federer
made people feel a certain way I think
it's the most popular player in the
history of the sport in terms of fan
support and and I think that you know
Roth has his supporters too but that's
what I'm saying is it just pure numbers
is is it is it more subjective than that
this conversation do you have a U.S open
Voice
and is it different from your college
football voice
I have a U.S open voice that Jennifer
says I bring home at night these matches
have been ended so late we're getting
home at one two in the morning she's
obviously asleep I come in she'll stir
and wake up and she claims that I'm
still in my booth voice
she's not wrong
try to leave the US Open voice out in
Flushing Meadows you're yelling dude
over 25
000 people yeah hours at a time and then
you come home yeah
a little differently it was really you
know and I I've been guilty of bringing
the voice home but yeah it's a little
bit different I mean you know
we could go for an hour and the
difference between calling the sports
but you know college football requires
an exuberance a different kind of energy
than even the NFL does tennis you watch
the point unfold you think during the
Long Point like 10 different things that
I should say when it's over they just
just discard them as the point continues
and then you you might say nothing at
the end so it's a lot more self-editing
where in football you just get out there
and you know you you just bring the
energy or you're going to get swallowed
up in a place like Tuscaloosa well you
can only imagine what Jim Nance sounds
like when he goes home
but I think he probably talks a lot
softer and smoother yeah yeah that's
what I'm saying even be like hello when
he walks in Hello friends the U.S open
Voice for me does not belong in the
bedroom
[Laughter]
great to talk to you have fun this
weekend thank you Chris all right Chris
Fowler ESPN college football announcer
and uh hosting are doing the announcing
at the US Open as well